[Music]
school's out indefinitely as parents
across America attempt to juggle their
work schedules with taking care of their
children full-time it's putting enormous
stress on families Carrie McDonald an
education researcher and author of
unschooled raising curious well-educated
children outside the conventional
classroom says that it's also an
opportunity to rethink how we teach our
children McDonald who also home schools
around for kids recommends that parents
experiment with radical unschooling
which proposes that kids learn better
when they direct their own education I
chatted with her about strategies for
struggling parents and why she thinks
that this crisis could finally move
society from the industrial to the
imagination
[Music]
Karrie thank you very much for chatting
with me today oh thanks for inviting me
Zack great to be with you first I know
there are a lot of parents out there who
were under a lot of stress the kids are
there they might be working from home
and having to juggle that with parenting
responsibilities they might be on leave
or out of work so I just want to be
clear from the top that these are not
exactly the ideal conditions for giving
homeschooling its first shot but
sometimes necessity is the mother of
invention well this is a really trying
time for all of us we're all
experiencing something that we've never
experienced before it's incredibly
stressful you point out you know we
parents and kids working and learning
alongside together alongside each other
in interruptions that might come with
that the you know stress of lots of
screen time for children and the effects
that that might have on family life and
just the overall uncertainty and fear
that brings us to this point and also
the fact that parents might have lost
jobs or not sure if they have jobs to go
back to when this all ends so it's an
incredibly difficult time for everyone
and you're absolutely right that this is
nothing like authentic homeschooling you
know traditional home schoolers and
unschoolers would tell you that this is
just as difficult for us as it is for
everyone else because we are so
separated from our communities I mean
the one thing that you find a lot of the
kind of modern home schoolers
experiencing is being immersed in the
people places and things of our
communities it's not the stereotype of
sitting around a kitchen table all day
isolated from the other outer world it's
really this authentic socialization in
our communities and of course all of us
are cut off from that experience right
now so I hope that people are not turned
off by homeschooling by this experience
that again is nothing like what they
would encounter in a genuine home
schooling experience but I do think it
can give some glimpses into what
learning without schooling
might look like a lot of closed down
schools have been sending homework home
and Dave you know sometimes daily emails
out to parents trying to keep students
on track as much as possible
I have very young kids who are in
preschool and even they're getting stuff
sent like every day but what's your
advice in terms of trying to you know
keep up with the curriculum during this
time according to the economists about a
billion students around the world are
out of school due to kovat 19 so this is
something that we're all contending with
of life without school at the moment and
different schools and different school
districts are managing this process
differently so in some cases young
people have a specific curriculum that
they must follow that the school has
sent home that maybe they're logging on
virtually from you know 8:00 to 3:00
every day and it's very much like a
typical school day except at home I
think we're also seeing though in many
cases any work that's being sent home is
the you consider an offer for enrichment
purposes only The Wall Street Journal
had an article about this recently
saying that in some major districts
education officials can't guarantee that
all students have equitable access to
technology or connectivity and as a
result of that they can't mandate any of
this work so you know we're seeing
schools and districts deal that's
different extent that parents have some
flexibility the extent that any work
that is being sent home is optional or
won't count toward grades or testing or
advancement I think it's a great
opportunity for families to disconnect
from schooling and see what it might be
like to learn without that sort of
standardized curriculum and that
expectation that we see from a standard
classroom what does the shift been like
for you someone who already had home
schools but obviously you're you're much
more constricted at this point right so
I'm located in Massachusetts and in
Boston Cambridge area and so we
and most of our time outside of our
homes taking classes in the community
going to the library going to museums
gathering with friends going to the park
and playgrounds all sorts of things that
of course we're not able to do and so
our lives have changed in very much the
same way that everyone's lives have
changed now again being isolated at home
disconnected from from friends
disconnected from our daily routines so
but what I can say it I do think that
homeschooling and the process of living
and learning alongside children is
something that families can begin to get
a glimpse of now in a way that they may
not otherwise have had that opportunity
to really get to know their kids a
little bit more what are some of their
interests what are some of their
curiosities and again until the extent
that families are able to move away from
a standardized curriculum or maybe just
spend a couple of hours a day on
whatever the school has sent home
leaving all kinds of unstructured time
with their children this may be a
wonderful opportunity for children's
natural creativity and curiosity to
re-emerge right I mean young children
are incredibly enthusiastic about
learning right they're always asking
questions you said you have young
children they are just full of energy
and excitement for discovery and then
what happens so often is they enter a
standard schooling situation and they
learn conformity and obedience and
compliance to a curriculum and so those
natural drives for learning can
sometimes be turned off and this is this
incredible moment to potentially turn
those drives for learning back on and to
see for example a reluctant reader all
of a sudden be really interested in
reading because you're giving that child
the freedom to read whatever he or she
isn't interested in or maybe you're
reading together as a family in ways
that you hadn't had a chance to before
when all of us were on the go and we had
so many activities in our own lives so
this could be a really great opportunity
for families to get gathered in together
and connect in ways that they otherwise
wouldn't the worry
that I often hear is well they're just
gonna sit around and play video games or
look at their phone all day is that how
do you get around that or do you just
like let them do that or are they
eventually gonna get bored and do
something else what's your advice with
regards to screen time and just being a
couch potato well I think there's two
responses to that there's the immediate
response of what we're all experiencing
currently where technology is frankly a
lifeline for parents and children alike
and so I think you know it's
understandable that parents have
concerns around technology under typical
circumstances I think you know often
just like sugar sometimes parents might
see the negative impact of too much
screen time on their children but I do
think that because we're in such
extraordinary circumstances right now we
should loosen some of those limits just
because it's again a way of connecting
with the outside world and not worry so
much about it I think that'll also take
some of the stress off of parents who
may be wearing oh my goodness my child
is watching so much TV or it's always on
on the tech on technology while I'm
trying to do calls or I'm trying to get
my work done and because this is such a
stressful situation for parents and
children children are just as stressed
and they're seeing the stress that
parents have I'm loosening a little bit
on those technology limits and not
feeling so bad about technology at least
in these early weeks of this I think is
really gonna take the pressure off of
families and be a relief the upside of
the technology that I've noticed is just
being able to you know the the social
isolation is obviously a big problem for
everyone and being able to FaceTime with
parents and even
you know friends and our preschool has
been doing zoom and ETOPS where they do
show-and-tell which has been fun for
them I mean what are some of the ways
that you've seen or recommend technology
actually be leveraged you know for
positive at this moment everything that
you have said I think we're seeing these
ways of virtual
connection through zoom and Google
Hangouts older kids are playing
minecraft video games through a
multiplayer world where you know they're
interacting with their friends or they
have face time with their friends while
they're playing the video game there's
another game called prodigy math which
is free and it's a wonderful math
software it's often used in the schools
as well and that's another multiplayer
kind of video game world so there are
these ways that kids can connect I've
seen also you know Google Docs some of
the materials being sent home from
schools are being put onto Google Docs
worksheets and assignments but you'll
find too that the kids when they're able
to collaborate with their friends and
their classmates might start using
Google Docs to develop a story together
or script together so there are these
wonderful ways to leverage technology
write negatively and and make up for
that lost physical connect and that
we're all fear I think the other reason
why we should loosen some of the limits
that we might have typically had on
technology at this point is because
there are so many resources free
resources now available to us
organizations that typically would
charge for their services many of them
are offering these free this free
content it's just really incredible you
have 2,500 museums around the world with
virtual tours you have symphony
orchestras that are streaming their
performances and then you know other
learning tools like Khan Academy of
course has always been free online
videos for kids they have more resources
for families even companies like varsity
tutors which is an online tutoring
platform that you would typically pay
for are offering their services for free
so there's this is just a unique
opportunity to be exposed to content and
experiences that we may otherwise not
have had a chance to a lot of parents
might be just worried that if especially
if we're talking about high school kids
that they're going to start just falling
behind in whatever subjects they're
they're currently studying how
concerning is that for you is and is
there any way to you know
at that if we're gonna be losing
possibly several months of time I think
there's a lot of talk about what's being
lost what is what learning isn't
occurring and I would like to flip that
a little say what learning will occur I
mean this experience is a defining
moment for all of us but particularly
for our children's childhood and their
lifetime this will be something that
they will look back on and that will
really shape their future and their
perspectives so there is an incredible
amount of learning for them over the
next several weeks or months and I think
that we should acknowledge just how much
they will learn and these new
perspectives they will gain and the one
story that I have found fascinating
that's come out of this pandemic is the
story of Isaac Newton who in 1665 was a
young college student in England and all
the colleges shut down due to the
bubonic plague that hit London and all
of the college students had to go back
to their homes just like is happening
now of course what we're experiencing
and Isaac Newton was one of those
college students went back to his
childhood home and it would be called
his year of Wonders when he was away
from professors and curriculum and his
typical assignments is when he invented
calculus and discovered gravity and came
up with his theory of optics because he
had this freedom to explore and to learn
and to discover and I think that could
be a model for us as difficult as this
is this could be an incredibly
productive period for both parents and
children it could really unleash some
creativity if we allow young people to
separate from a schooling mindset hmm so
yeah this the schooling mindset is
really what you go after in your book
that you're trying to separate the idea
of learning from formal schooling and
and that brings us to the topic of
what's become known as unschooling and
it's an it's an educational philosophy
that began
pick up steam in the 80s as espoused by
an educator named John Holt school is a
place where children learn to be stupid
the process that makes them stupidly
stupid in school is other people trying
to control their learning that's John
Holt who's the intellectual Godfather of
the modern home schooling movement in a
sense he's the moral leader of a
movement in this country on the part of
a significant number of American
families to take their kids out of
school and teach them at home there's a
common perception that home schoolers
are social conservatives who want to
shield their children from the modern
world it's good for the child to get out
of the home get away from mom and dad
and talk to other people because when
they become adults they've got that
problem but Holt had a different view of
the dangers of school in his 10 books
Holt argued that children were capable
of self-directed learning possessing a
natural curiosity that's quashed by
modern schools they treat them like an
empty receptacles into which they are
going to pour one such example is the
Houston Sudbury school based on the
Sudbury Valley School model pioneered in
Massachusetts in 1968 students here who
range in age from 6 to 17 play and learn
with each other attend optional lessons
in various subjects and each have an
equal vote on how the school is run and
money allocated so what are the insights
from the unschooling philosophy that you
think are most applicable to our current
situation he defined unschooling as
taking children out of school it has
since evolved I think to be more
associated with this idea of
self-directed education so if we think
of typical homeschooling some
homeschooling families might replicate
school at home and so all that's really
changing in terms of Education is the
location and unschoolers or those who
sort of both focus more on the
self-directed education philosophy would
say that schooling is one method of
Education regardless of if it takes
place in a school or some other location
but there's other ways to be educated
and in allowing people to set their own
path to focus on their own interests and
passions so much learning will occur and
of course as I say in my book and I and
I repeat frequently it's a parent's
responsibility to ensure that their
children are highly literate and
numerate that they're well educated I
think that that's true whether your
children are in school or out of school
but I think there are ways that we can
facilitate those about that strong
education and these curious individuals
by allowing for a non-coercive learning
environment that stimulates their
interests and passions and reveals their
gifts the person who wrote the
introduction to your book Peter gray a
psychologist who studied this kind of
self-directed learning when he observed
the original Sudbury school and that the
Sudbury School which we we referenced
one in the previous clip it basically
allows kids not only to make their own
curriculum but kind of democratically
come up with the rules of the school
itself could you give us some highlights
of whatever research is actually out
there about self-directed learning and
what kind of results we see whether
whether or not it actually works just
for parents who are worried about you
know kind of unleashing their kids and
really no learning of any sort happening
I think it's important to note that even
under the umbrella term of unschooling
there is a wide assortment of approaches
and different ways that families tackle
self-directed education so and I and I
highlight the Houston Sudbury school in
my own school book as well as a variety
of other self-directed learning centers
unschooling families unschooling alumni
and you see this diversity of practice
and and approaches I think the the
underlying focus though is on this sense
of having learning be
non-coercive so really focusing on
freedom over force and encouraging
individual gifts to emerge within our
children so some of the research and
your rights to point out Peter Gray
who's just such a wonderful advocate for
self-directed education unschooling is
something fantastic research in this
area one of the surveys that he and the
colleague did on grown unschoolers found
that grown unschoolers
had no trouble getting into college
should they choose many of them took
community college classes during their
teenage years and did fine and took the
SATs and did fine and then were able to
enter college did fine they were able to
adapt effectively to college and to
college and career but I thought one of
the most interesting findings from this
particular survey of bronan schoolers
was that more than half of individuals
survey jobs that were entrepreneurial
tied to interests that emerged during
childhood or adolescence so the sense of
encouraging personal agency creativity
and an entrepreneurial spirit can really
be cultivated through unschooling the
pandemic right now it's causing a lot of
people to question things about the
world I think and their assumptions some
people have the sense that a lot of
things are gonna be permanently changed
after this much in the same way 9/11
shifted the paradigm in many areas of
our lives
instead of sense you have when it comes
to how we view education in America will
this permanently shake things up in some
fundamental way or is this really kind
of a blip look many families are going
to be delighted to get back to their
typical routines of work in school I
think all of us will be very glad when
this is over and we can return to a
sense of normalcy but I would be very
surprised if we don't see an uptick in
families choosing homeschooling or
virtual learning or some other kind of
alternative to school
I'm already seeing this a neighbor of
mine for instance just said when I asked
at a six-foot distance how's it going
and she said oh my child is just
flourishing she is writing stories she's
reading books she's devouring math and I
said you know gee maybe you'll continue
this out she said we're really going to
consider this I think that's going to be
the case for some families especially
families that have been intrigued by the
idea of homeschooling
or an alternative to school this is
their moment to give it a shot
and they made again their kids are
calmer they're happier they're more
curious they're doing interesting things
they're learning amazing things without
schooling which will be I think
revealing for the parents and they'll
want to continue that and I so I really
think we're on the brink of a real
education reset in the same way the
Hurricane Katrina caused a huge
education shift in New Orleans after the
hurricane in 2005 and Terri mo from
Stanford University wrote a book
recently called the politics of
institutional reform where he
spotlighted how Hurricane Katrina led to
in nearly all charter school district
New Orleans that really couldn't have
happened had it not been for that level
of a disaster a natural disaster to
break up some bureaucracies and cause
some real institutional ships speaking
of charter schools I wonder like whether
or not homeschooling per se takes off
like is this the self-directed learning
approach is there any hope of getting
that incorporated a bit more into school
like traditional schools or charter
schools or I believe John Holt would
himself believe that was not a
possibility which is why he advocated
homeschooling but where do you fall on
that do you think it's just kind of
impossible to reform the schools in this
way and homeschooling is the only path
forward if you want a more self-directed
approach or are there ways to implement
some of this in the
system well as I was writing my book I
was very hopeful for an experiment just
outside of Boston near me in Somerville
Massachusetts was to be a fully
self-directed high school district
school would not a charter school and it
was really aiming to incorporate these
unschooling principles the founder was
influenced by John Holden davon Ilic
definitely believed in this idea of
allowing emergent learning to occur and
not having it be a top-down process it
was it was this dream school if we were
to imagine anything that was to happen
in a public school looking like
unschooling this was it in fact they won
a 10 million dollar grant from the XQ
super schools innovative school fund
because the idea was so exciting and
promising and everything was set up
they had superintendent support they had
teachers union support the community was
really excited about it and as my book
went to print they were set to open this
past fall of 2019 and in March so just
like a month or two before my book came
out last year the school community
unanimously decided not to approve the
opening of the school and it just a shot
and then PR wrote a big piece about at
the Boston Globe because it was really
set up in so many ways to be this one
experiment to see if self-directed
learning could happen in school with
everything going for it and then to have
it to have it paused in that way or
halted really was just heartbreaking and
the main reason was the sense that
because not everyone could participate
in this school then no one could yeah
that's that doesn't bode well the I mean
the the biggest cuz the biggest hurdle I
see like for homeschooling honestly is
that when you have two working parents
it seems difficult if not impossible and
like dual-income households seem to have
been holding steady for a couple decades
now around six
% it almost seems like homes like for
home schooling or unschooling to really
take off people would need to adopt a
whole different mindset which you do
discuss a little bit in your book if
there anything that leads you to believe
that a new mindset is emerging or
forthcoming I think families are finding
that they can adopt homeschooling and
unschooling and continue to be two
working parents or single parents for
example even just again this experiment
with digital learning families will
realize that they don't have to be the
ones sitting down and teaching their
children that there are these incredible
resources available that can educate
their children like Khan Academy can can
manage a child's math education or my
older daughter it takes Korean classes
and it's a Korean tutor who is she's
working with
I don't know Korean so as a parent we're
just connecting our children to
available resources
I think another trend that we're seeing
is the hybrid homeschooling models where
a young person might go to a learning
center or a micro school for a couple of
days a week or even potentially
full-time but our registered as home
schoolers so so homeschooling really
becomes the legal lever to put parents
back in charge of their child's
education and allow for this freedom and
flexibility that wouldn't be possible
with typical public or private schools
so there's much more flexibility there
again around hybrid homeschooling
networks of low-cost in-home microscope
Renda my crystal network coming out of
Arizona
in some cases for that one there too
it's tied to virtual charter schools and
education savings accounts these other
kinds of school choice mechanisms that
can allow for some more education
innovation experimentation so I think
we're going to see much more of that
I think after families have a taste of a
different kind of education they're
going to demand more education choice
they're going to want more options and
hopefully will also encourage more
education entrepreneurship to build
these new models
it's interest
because yeah you're kind of changing the
way that I've thought about
homeschooling a little bit in terms of
you imagine the parents more as the
teacher and and what you're sketching
out here the parent is kind of just
shepherding the child towards different
areas of interest or education options
which makes sense because not everyone
is a good teacher you're kind of
questioning the fundamentals of the
current education system and I feel like
to really understand why those need
questioning it helps to understand why
it is the way in the first place and
again your book does delve into this and
you zero in on Horace Mann and the
Prussian model it's kind of the starting
point what was going on back in the
early 19th century that laid the
foundation for what we have today well I
think it's it's even further back than
that so if we go back to the 1640s not
long after the Pilgrims landed in Matt
what was then Massachusetts Bay Colony
they established the colony's first
compulsory education law that said that
the state has an interest in educated
citizenry but the compulsion was on
towns city and cities and towns of
certain sizes would have to hire a
teacher and or open and operate a
grammar school so it was the town that
was required by the state to provide
education resources for those families
that wanted them but it was not the
parents who were required to send their
children there and in fact homeschooling
was of course the default the
expectation was that parents would be
the ones educating their children but
they weren't always the ones doing that
education even then there were Dame
schools which were like these little
nursery schools in your neighbor's
kitchen to teach young kids the 3 R's
and let their mom you know get things
done around the house there were
apprenticeship programs there were
tutors that would come and offer
guidance so an array of different
education approaches and of course
public and private schools were also
available um
this all changes in 1852 when Horace
Mann and his colleagues become the
architects of of compulsory schooling
and so for the first time parents are
compelled to send their children to
school under a legal threat of force and
that was a huge sea change from what
education was previously and you're
absolutely right that it was these
education reformers in the mid
nineteenth century who were fascinated
by the Prussian model of Education that
focused on obedience and compliance and
orderliness and and coercion really - to
build a solid group of factory workers
that would help you know build the the
Industrial Revolution really and that
was exciting to a lot of these reformers
this was also time of mass emigration
particularly in Massachusetts a lot of
Irish Catholic immigrants pouring into
the streets of Boston in particular
which threatens the dominant anglo-saxon
Protestant ethos of the time and so
common in schools these compulsory
schools that were created were really
designed to Americanize these immigrants
and to to teach them what it was like to
live an appropriate life in in the
United States so they were purportedly
secular but they had the King James
Bible they had Protestant teachers and
they really had a specific worldview
that a lot of families including
Catholics rejected and actually went off
and created their own network of
Catholic schools to get away from that
that sort of system systemized methods
of Education yeah and I mean an
interesting fact I picked up from your
book was that man actually homeschooled
his own kids so the kind of rigid was
like rigid compulsory schooling for to
me but not for thee I feel like we still
see that dynamic at play sometimes in
the education debate
we do I think that that hypocrisy of
well this is for other people's children
but not for my children or you know I
will continue to exercise choice for my
kids but we have to make sure that
everyone else is forced into a
government system of mass schooling that
is the is the piece that I think is is
you really need to call out that's the
most frustrating and the really the most
pernicious so if the motivation or I
guess the effect of the horse man
Prussian approach was to kind of prepare
workers for this industrial base that
then would fuel the Industrial
Revolution we're now in a different era
but this this model still persists to
some degree you call it in your book you
say that a lot of people talk about the
Information Age but you call it the
imagination age what does that mean to
you why you think we're in the
imagination age what is that mean for
schooling and what does that mean you
know for the future
right so I didn't coin the term the
imagination age I go through some of its
evolution in the book it's often called
the innovation era but it's basically
you know the next stage after the
Industrial Revolution right and even in
some ways past the Information Age where
human creativity and imagination are
really are going to separate us from
robots and yet we have a system of
compulsory mass schooling but from the
19th century that is very efficient at
creating what are essentially robotic
humans you go through these this orderly
process and you take all the boxes and
then you come out all shiny and learn at
the end and I think what we're seeing is
that through that process often those
essential human qualities of creativity
and curiosity and inventiveness and an
entrepreneurial spirit can be crushed or
at least dull and yet those are the
human qualities that are so critical as
we as we coexist with robots you know
what separates humans from robots it is
these essential human qualities around
human imagination that will create the
the next great inventions and hopefully
enable us to prevent or better deal with
some of these global crises like we're
currently experiencing and I mean as
this global crisis kind of belatedly
kicks off the 21st century here what do
you see as a realistic path towards
improving the way American kids get
educated moving forward once the dust
settles from the pandemic yes I think
again and families will see a different
way of learning they will hopefully
among all of the stress and tension that
they're experiencing at home we'll find
those moments where they can connect
with their children in ways they weren't
able to before and see how much they
really are able to learn when they're
given the freedom to do that and again
because we have these incredible digital
resources for free right now to take
advantage of I think parents will also
see that it's really the technology that
will make self-directed education or
other education models more possible
because of the ways that technology and
provides us with all of these different
resources and approaches so it's not
just families feeling a pressure that
they have to educate their children it's
really seeing that that technology can
can facilitate that and in some ways
it's also looking at how we as adults
learn whether it's now through this
pandemic I mentioned Isaac Newton on
devouring the biographies about Isaac
Newton now and and watching you know
documentaries about him but I think it's
also recognizing again the way adults
learn what how do we become interested
in things and then what do we do to
satisfy that curiosity and increasingly
it's using digital technology to do that
and I think it's just acknowledging that
young people learn the same way they
have those they have their own interests
and their own passions and they'll be
able to leverage technology as
then once we emerge from our social
distancing
back into our communities then we're
connected with all those meal resources
as well that make learning that much
more rewarding and impactful
[Music]